on se serait cru à angoulême au salon de
la bd tout à l'heure à saint-andré
suivant en effet baptisé l'école
primaire d'une de rené goscinny s'était
bien sûr le permet eric de lucky luke
beaucoup d'autres albums de bandes
dessinées avec départ après si je les
épices la rue des roseaux bilal marge de
shania il n'y avait pas de rapport entre
savoir et / ou négocié et pourtant ils
étaient tous venus ils sont entrés dans
leur classe comme d'habitude mais
aujourd'hui le prof de dessin et est lui
loin d'être habituel enki bilal de son
maître du temps de rené goscinny ici à
saint-andré / en cdm affaire qui m'a
donné ma chance cette année
donc le fait d'être présent ici point
pour ce matin toutefois faussée bien que
mes enfants soient grâce qui va les
frapper avec demi moore
je regarde le nom ce sont les élèves de
l'ancienne école qui l'ont choisi pour
cette inauguration aux normes 15 ans
tout juste après le décès de goscinny
ses amis avaient rallié leur mentir
masse dit vidal ferry brouillet gilberte
goscinny la fille de rené
albert uderzo le complice pierre
tchernia et frank margerin la photo de
famille traditionnelle et
d'inconventionnalité finalement que peu
d'importance pour les enfants de la
nouvelle école rené goscinny qui comme
je lis garderont le vivarium margerin
uderzo à quelques euros près de 1000
images par toutatis
non